[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous êtes
sur le plateau dès maintenant l'émission
qui revient avec plaisir et avec vous
sur l'actualité politique de la semaine
vous connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui les amis c'est un plateau à
plusieurs étoiles il y a de l'expérience
il y a de la fougue il a Fabrice
Dalmeida sur ce plateau bonjour
de l'université Panthéon Assas vous êtes
l'auteur du livre l'histoire mondiale
des riches c'est à retrouver chez plomb
merci d'être là votre voisine n'est plus
à présenter Michel cotta bonjour vous
êtes éditorialiste à Europa merci d'être
sur ce plateau n'attend deux verres
bonjour vous êtes écrivain et philosophe
vous avez signé des liens artificiels
aux éditions Albin Michel et Hélène
Terzian bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste politique irmc ravi de vous
accueillir dans cette émission on fera
le bilan de la carrière politique de
Silvio Berlusconi qui nous a quitté
cette semaine on se demandera si Poutine
a réveillé l'OTAN si la gauche anti mél
est en train de se réveiller de sa
torpeur et puis et puis Emmanuel Macron
doit-il mettre définitivement malencia
pas en veille vous me direz dans un
instant merci président Larcher mais
d'abord qui aura la peau d'Elizabeth
borne peut-être personne dans la
première Mini sacroche à son fauteuil on
la disait condamné à la démission la
pensée fragilisée après une série de
recadrage du chef de l'État mais pour
l'instant c'est bien elle qui est au
manette du gouvernement elle a échappé
cette semaine à une 17e motion de
censure des députés écoutez
tombe le convaincu que le courage
politique c'est une opposition vocale
caricaturale totale moi je ne confonds
pas le courage et les décibels le vrai
courage politique c'est de sortir du
confort de la posture de la course aux
petites phrases de construire des
majorités même avec ceux qui ne pensent
pas exactement comme nous 17e émotion de
censure éviter Fabrice ça démontre la
faiblesse des oppositions ou l'habiliter
d'Elizabeth borne
le caractère efficace de la procédure
qui était faite justement pour permettre
à un gouvernement de tenir face à des
oppositions j'allais dire un géométrie
variable donc ça c'est un premier point
deuxième point c'est quand même que
Elisabeth borne a réussi quelque chose
dans l'opinion publique française
c'est-à-dire que même si elle est pas
forcément la plus aimée le sentiment
qu'au fond c'est le bon petit soldat
vaillant qui fait le travail qui essaye
de résister et là encore ce qu'elle dit
assez bien c'est ce sentiment de
résistance et ben je crois que ça ça
imprime quelque chose après c'est vrai
qu'il y a un tel une telle lassitude de
du macronisme telle lassitude du
gouvernement que il faut essayer pour le
président de renouveler quelque chose ça
on comprend mais on va en parler on est
encore montré ce chiffre du nombre de
motions de censure
historique sous la Cinquième République
et Elisabeth borne a donc échappé à 17
motions de censure c'est le record sur
la 5e il y avait Georges Pompidou et
Georges Pompidou on avait évité 7 et
Bombard 7 Pierre Mauroy 7 et Michel
Rocard 6
Michel cotta c'est 17 motions de censure
éviter qu'est-ce que ça nous dit
d'Élisabeth borne ou peut-être du
système institutionnel dans lequel on
est aujourd'hui le système
institutionnel c'est la majorité de
Native voilà ce que ça nous dit parce
que on cite la le nombre de fois où il y
a eu d'émotions de censure mais enfin
Michel Rocard je vous rappelle la
gouverner avec 28
49 années à trois donc bon c'est une
majoritaire relative quand c'est une
majorité relative c'est un peu
inévitable alors sur le caractère de
bornes au fond
Emmanuel Macron qui a fixé le cap en
disant dans les 100 jours faire des
choses qui n'est pas arrivé à faire
lui-même avant avec un changement ma
commodement de la majorité tout ça
paraît effectivement impossible donc on
peut toujours au bout des 100 jours dire
bah non elle a pas réussi mais en fait
qui n'aura pas réussi c'est aussi le
président de la République c'est dans ce
cas donc moi je trouve qu'il faut être
très prudent sur la limogeage ou le
départ
d'Elizabeth borne parce que c'est ouvrir
aussi beaucoup de critiques directes sur
le président de la République justement
sur le départ éventuel d'Elisabeth band
on va écouter Olivier Véran cette
semaine puisqu'il nous a appris et bien
qu'Emmanuel Macron l'avait félicité sa
première ministre cette semaine écoutez
vos nouvelles vont effectivement très
vite c'était le cas le président de la
République a félicité la première
ministre après le rejet de la 17e motion
de censure un rejet massif d'ailleurs de
cette tentative de censure
c'était franc et c'était je sais pas ce
que vous appelez soutien franc mais oui
il a félicité la première ministre elle
est condamnée Isabelle borne en tout cas
elle semble insubmersible elle montre
qu'elle est en submersible Elizabeth
band encore une fois dans les colonnes
du Figaro il y a quelques jours elle
disait que son ADN c'était de ne pas
baisser les bras et elle fait un peu
comme si de rien n'était elle fait
quelques tacles à son équipe elle dit
qu'elle doit avoir une équipe un peu
plus musclée en disant que ces ministres
doivent savoir parler au Parlement
échanger avec les sénateurs les députés
portaient porter des textes et puis
elles parlent des chantiers qu'elle va
continuer à lancer qu'elle entend bien
mener harcèlement scolaire écologie
ruralité encore hier on entendait
Olivier Veyron dire que le président
entre guillemets avait félicité ils
avaient de borne le Président il souffle
le show et le froid avec Elizabeth
borgne et encore deux semaines on disait
qu'il avait recadré sa première ministre
sur l'histoire de la façon dont on
devait s'attaquer au rassemblement
national donc il souffle le chaud et le
froid on sait contre le les deux têtes
de l'exécutif c'est un petit peu
compliqué quand même ce n'était pas le
premier choix Elizabeth borne du
président de la République donc toujours
compliqué
de la poudre de merci Président c'est un
peu toujours problématique dans les
relations entre président et première
ministre et Premier ministre en général
mais est-ce que le duo exécutif Macron
borne est plus problématique et plus
difficile à gérer que les précédents du
haut Nathan il me semble qu'il y a une
singularité chez Emmanuel Macron en
général dans son choix de tous ces
premiers ministres depuis Edouard
Philippe c'est qu'il a systématiquement
fait le choix et c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de la Cinquième
République de choisir des individus qui
ne soient pas des présidentielles
ensuite ils peuvent le devenir dans le
cas d'Edouard Philippe mais en tout cas
et c'est la première fois que il y a eu
un président qui n'a jamais été menacé
dans ses intérêts politiques pendant son
mandat par un premier ministre ou un
ancien de ses anciens Premier ministre à
lui et ça c'est une singularité et il me
semble d'ailleurs que c'est ce qui est
dangereux sur la perspective d'un
remaniement c'est que vraisemblablement
Emmanuel Macron le critère majeur pour
lui c'est de prendre quelqu'un qui ne
lui fera pas d'ombre avec des élections
présidentielles dans quelques années et
un rassemblement national qui fait des
scores aussi élevés c'est une stratégie
me semble-t-il qui est assez dangereuse
et si on revient sur les frictions qu'il
y a eu entre Elisabeth borne et em
Macron il me semble que dans les deux
cas Elizabeth borne avait raison
politiquement la première friction c'est
quand Elisabeth borne avait dit quand la
réforme des retraites sera finie il
faudra repenser à zéro le quinquennat
enfin les quatre années qui restent
faire une grande table rase un reset
réfléchir et Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas
supporté qu'elle parle ainsi comme si
elle était président de la
républiquement en l'occurrence elle
avait raison sur le fond ça veut dire
sur la nécessité après une une séquence
absolument impopulaire de dire
maintenant il faut vraiment faire un
travail de réflexion et évidemment sur
le rassemblement national où elle avait
rappelé des faits historiques et
qu'Emmanuel Macron lui répond que
rappelait d'effet historiques c'est un
argument moral elle avait également
raison donc c'est pourquoi il me semble
que évidemment qu'elle est associée une
bonne première ministre si je comprends
bien première ministre qui est associée
à une réforme qui est impopulaire qui
est antisocial donc cette critique là je
l'entends mais si c'est pour la
remplacer par quelqu'un d'encore moins
présidentiable et qui serait aligné sur
sur les positions d'Emmanuel Macron
quand deux sujets que je vous ai dit il
me semble que là ce serait ce serait
dangereux
avec Nathan on va avoir un débat de
Gaulle fait le même calcul quand il
prend de brés de brun n'est pas
présidentielle quand il prend Pompidou
Pompidou n'est pas du tout président et
quand il prend en couple de Murville
inutile de dire qu'il était absolument
pas présidentiel donc il avait lu aussi
l'idée qu'il fallait des gens qui soient
de bons collaborateurs thèmes qui
l'emploi d'ailleurs et qu'on a reproché
par la suite d'ailleurs à Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est quoi le secret d'un
remaniement réussi Michel ça si j'en
avais
un secret je suppose que si on le
connaissait on le dirait je voudrais
reprendre
Elizabeth borne c'est vrai que elle a
raison sur sur les deux points que vous
avez dit c'est vrai aussi que Macron n'a
pas tort de dire que on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui attaquer le rassemblement
national sur Vichy et il a raison de le
dire c'est pas une argument moral c'est
que beaucoup de gens qui sont venus au
rassemblement national je sais même pas
qui est Pétain donc c'est un argument
pour euh
oui parce qu'ils sont arrivés à la voix
des jeunes qui
une autre ministre qui est sur la
sellette c'est Marlène Schiappa mais je
pense qu'on en reparlera juste après en
tout cas les ministres dit
issus de la société civile comme
François Brune et pas Ndiaye aujourd'hui
il gère leur écosystème visiblement très
bien on n'entend pas trop les critiques
au sein de leur été un site de leur de
leur écosystème les profs ça va plutôt
bien ils sont plutôt ils sont plutôt
silencieux donc ça a l'air de
fonctionner les professionnels de santé
un petit peu plus vont me direz mais bon
en tout cas il vient de cet écosystème
François Bron donc on estime on peut
penser qu'il a du mal en fait à se
sortir de ce rôle là ce sont clairement
eux qui sont visés aujourd'hui et eux
qui sont sur la sellette le profil type
de remplaçant éventuels ce serait quoi
Fabrice
il y a eu un débat mais je suis très
sceptique là-dessus il y a l'idée de la
droitisation du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire essayer de chercher
quelqu'un chez les LR mais c'est vrai
que plus le temps passe plus les les
potentiels candidats paraissent soit
faible soit décalé soit pas forcément
plus efficace ni profitable la carte de
l'alliance avec les LR ce serait pas
forcément une carte intéressante à jouer
pour Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui ben
comme il dit c'est je crois que c'est
une citation qu'il a eu il a dit on a
payé pour voir déjà sur la réforme des
retraites ils ont essayé de monter
quelque chose avec eux ils ont vu la
direction du parti ils avaient fait une
stratégie ensemble et tout a été miné
par Pradier et d'autres donc je crois
que c'est compliqué aujourd'hui de de
changer de changer d'axe en réalité je
crois pas qu'il est la possibilité de
faire autre chose que ce qu'il a fait
avec borne c'est-à-dire d'avoir
quelqu'un qui soit comme le disait
Nathan un bon collaborateur et qui
puisse aider et si je dis ça je j'ai en
tête le fait qu'il a rencontré début
juin Nicolas Sarkozy et qu'il faut se
souvenir qu'on a eu exactement les mêmes
débats autour du gouvernement Fillon
est-ce qu'il fallait un deuxième
gouvernement est-ce que c'était le bon
moment et finalement Fillon est resté
tout le quinquennat et je me demande si
quel est l'intérêt en fait aujourd'hui
de changer de Premier ministre pour pour
Emmanuel Macron sachant que il va pas
vers une réélection donc voilà et ce qui
veut faire monter et est-ce que les gens
qui veulent faire monter n'ont pas peur
de se brûler les ailes comme Manuel
Valls les ai brûlés en son temps Michel
quel intérêt le danger moi je vois le
danger et le danger par exemple ce que
vous soulignez si c'est ce dont tout le
monde de celui dont tout le monde parle
Juliette Normandie il apparaîtra
forcément
l'agriculture comme un collaborateur de
base
d'Emmanuel Macron désigner un peu avec
le droit du prince en quelque sorte
alors je ne vois pas ce qui Emmanuel
Macron a gagné
bon c'est je crois que ça lui ramènera
pas de toute façon les républicains
effectivement il a dû avoir comme
préoccupation de se ramener sur beaucoup
de plans les républicains mais c'est pas
dit qu'un ancien républicain qui a entre
guillemets trahi ce que les républicains
n'arrêtent pas de dire soit le meilleur
et qui Clive la majorité également cette
histoire du remaniement s'intéresse
beaucoup évidemment les journalistes les
Français s'ils sont intéressés vraiment
on attend à ça éventuel remaniement quel
impact ça aura dans l'opinion de parler
au nom des au nom des Français mais j'ai
l'impression que que peut peut-être que
je me trompe mais je me sens d'ailleurs
que ceux qui sait jouer là depuis la
dernière élection présidentielle c'est
que les Français ont voté disons par
défaut dans un cas de barrage
républicains et encore une fois ça fait
maintenant enfin Emmanuel Macron a
construit toute sa carrière politique
avec des élections où il a été élu
systématiquement dans des conjonctures
deux barrages républicains donc c'était
jamais des votes d'adhésion et c'était
jamais même des votes de rejet mais face
à un candidat normal et si vous voulez
et puis au lieu de tenir compte de cela
c'est à dire du fait qu'il n'y avait
absolument pas d'adhésion sur son
programme il y a eu quand même depuis un
an il y a eu ce moment où il y a une
politique qui ne tient aucun compte de
l'état des lieux donc j'ai l'impression
il y a une forme de décalage très très
fort entre non seulement entre les
opposants à Emmanuel Macron et Emmanuel
Macron ce qui est une évidence mais même
entre une partie des gens qui ont qui
ont voté pour lui et que dans cette
mesure là peu d'attente ce projet sur le
sur le remaniement dans ce remaniement
éventuel avenir faut-il sauver le soldat
Marlène Schiappa la secrétaire des têtes
actuellement mise en cause dans la
gestion du fond mariage une structure
créée en 2021 réponse à l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty ce mercredi elle a été
auditionnée par une commission d'enquête
du Sénat elle appelait des l'ignorance
écoutez là me défausse pas je me dé
repas je suis là devant vous et
j'entends endosser ma responsabilité
toute ma responsabilité pardon pour la
formulation mais aussi rien que ma
responsabilité j'ai toujours en toute
circonstances pris à mes responsabilités
j'ai énormément de défauts mais
certainement pas celui de me dérober
alors on va pas rentrer vraiment dans le
détail de cette affaire il faut savoir
qu'il y a déjà trois procédures en cours
une procédure judiciaire puisqu'une
information judiciaire a été ouverte
pour détournement de fonds publics il y
a eu des perquisitions qui ont été mener
il y a aussi une enquête administrative
et donc cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire qui a été lancée ici au
Sénat c'est un boulet politique cette
affaire pour Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
franchement c'est pas bon du tout quoi
parce que c'est vrai que c'était quand
même le président qui se présentait un
peu comme l'homme de la transparence
l'homme de du retrait du vieux monde des
mauvaises affaires et puis que petit à
petit au fur et à mesure de son
quinquennat il y a eu comme ça quelques
bombes qui ont explosé celle-là je
dirais que c'est la plus ennuyeuse parce
que elle s'entre sur une histoire qui a
été une émotion intense pour la France
exactement et là-dessus il décide de
mettre en place pour lutter contre les
séparatismes expression de l'époque donc
voilà à définir mais pour lutter contre
ça il faut financer des formes de
communication des formes d'éducation des
interventions dans les lycées et c'est
cet argent là qui va être mal employé et
c'est d'autant plus dramatique qu'il y a
des acteurs de ce dossier qui se mettent
en position
vraiment combatif je pense à Mohamed
cifaoui qui sent son honneur mais en
cause et qui au Sénat comme dans les
médias a des phrases assassines pour
Marlène Schiappa donc je pense que c'est
très dur pour le pour le président de
voir aussi celle qui était un peu le
symbole de du précédent quinquennat et
qui a été une des rares maintenue avec
les deux poids lourds qu'on a mentionné
notamment le maire et Darmanin mais
c'est une des rares qui est survécu à
cette à ce premier quinquennat et donc
oui je pense que ça fait pas du bien
vous avez parlé de Mohamed Sifaoui
l'essayiste on va justement l'entendre
puisqu'il était auditionné cette semaine
par le Sénat et c'était une édition très
agitée il y a eu quelques clashs avec
les sénateurs il met en cause lui
directement Marlène Schiappa écoutez-le
elle n'est pas mon ami elle n'a pas été
elle est pas aujourd'hui elle sera
encore moins demain vous savez pourquoi
j'ai dit ça je devais pas le dire
dis ça parce que je n'aime pas les gens
qui n'ont pas de courage
je ne respecte pas les gens qui n'ont
pas de courage je vous l'ai dit Madame
Schiappa est innocente mais je l'ai dit
deux dès le départ son attitude est
curieuse elle a une attitude de
quelqu'un qui est coupable faut-il
sauver le soldat Schiappa du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron deux invités sur ce
plateau ne sont pas d'accord c'est ce
qu'on appelle un duel Michel 45 secondes
pour développer vos arguments d'un côté
et bien on retrouve Hélène de l'autre
Michel Hélène vous allez commencer 45
secondes pour nous dire pourquoi selon
vous et bien non il faut pas garder je
sais pas au gouvernement aujourd'hui oui
je pense que ça devient intenable pour
un Marlène Chapa aujourd'hui jusqu'à
maintenant vous le disiez Fabrice
dalmella elle était là tout d'Emmanuel
Macron il macroniste pur jus 2016-2017
était la seule femme qu'on retenait au
gouvernement elle allait sur les
plateaux elle sortait des radars
traditionnels maintenant elle devient je
pense un boulet pour le gouvernement
extrêmement fragilisé dans le l'affaire
du fond marine elle a une défense
extrêmement poussive et puis par la une
de ce magazine de charme Playboy
enveloppée dans un drapeau tricolore en
pleine réforme des retraites quand des
millions de gens sont dans la rue je
pense que c'est une faute politique
morale c'est ce que me disent certains
macronistes un conseiller ministériel me
disait elle pouvait se permettre ce type
de déroute quand elle faisait avancer
ses dossiers notamment au secrétariat
égalité homme-femme aujourd'hui elle ne
fait pas avancer le dossier elle ne peut
plus le permettre n'est pas du tout
d'accord vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi il faut sauver le soldats
Schiappa moi je ne voudrais pas me
situer sur le cas particulier de Madame
Schiappa je suis absolument d'accord sur
le drapeau tricolore et la nudité sur
c’était vraiment ça s'imposait pas il
reste que la jurisprudence
baptisée baladure ou Bérégovoy comme
vous voulez
me semble terminé à partir du moment il
me semble qu'on ne peut plus se séparer
d'un ministre lorsqu'il est mis en
examen
parce que l'attitude des juges de toute
façon générale est une attitude très
hostile à la politique par conséquent
c'est eux en quelque sorte qui dicterait
au gouvernement qui doit en sortir et
qui doit y rester en revanche on peut se
poser des questions sur est-ce qu'on se
débarrasse d'un ministre quand il
devient gênant c'est autre chose je
précise juste donc pour cette
jurisprudence berlingova baladio ça veut
dire sanction des missions avant même
une décision d'examen avant même le
nombre de gens qui ont été qui après ont
connu la grâce du tribunal est
considérée c'est la fin de cette
jurisprudence définitivement avec
Emmanuel Macron il y a eu d'autres
histoires évidemment
sur lesquelles on pourrait revenir Éric
Dupond-Moretti Gérald Darmanin
Macron a acté la fin de cette
jurisprudence selon vous
oui mais il me semble que sur ce point
il a pas nécessairement tort c'est à
dire que la séparation des pouvoirs
implique évidemment que l'exécutif n'a
pas à interférer sur le judiciaire mais
que ce n'est pas le judiciaire qui fixe
le calendrier de la vie politique et la
présomption d'innocence si c'est juste
un principe un principe très abstrait
consistant à dire vous perdez vos amis
vous perdez votre métier vous perdez
toute votre vie sociale mais par contre
vous êtes présumé innocent alors ça fait
une belle jambe si vous voulez vous
accuser que d'être prise mais innocent
donc il me semble important quand
quelqu'un est mis en examen de de même
si la mise en examen c'est réunion de
faisceaux d'indices concordants et
graves etc mais quand même de ne pas se
hâter vers une conclusion d'accusation
et concernant Marlène Schiappa il me
semble je parle pas du fond Marianne je
parle vraiment de son action politique
moi je trouve au contraire que dans ce
gouvernement c'est un petit peu une des
seules qui est vraiment dans une
démarche de sincérité depuis le début de
sa vie d'ailleurs je parle même pas de
sa vie politique sa vie c'est les
premiers engagements ses écrits ses
engagements associatifs etc c'est à dire
que elle a deux trois causes qui lui
tiennent vraiment à cœur et qu'elle
défend de manière on ne fait très orig
inale de manière qui peut être clivante
mais je trouve qu'il y a chez elle une
forme d'authenticité et que ce serait
dommage de se séparer alors d'elle je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas de cette idée
que un ministre doit être authentique
les réactions politiques à cette affaire
ne manquent pas certains demandent bien
évidemment la démission de Marlène shop
à écouter
trois heures d'audition pour une
ministre qui nous dit en substance ce
n'est pas moi c'est mon administration
quand c'est pas mon administration c'est
les membres de mon cabinet je crois
qu'on attend de la part de ministre une
responsabilité assumée et de tirer les
conséquences de son irresponsabilité
quand elle est constatée par les faits
l'émissionner des missionné séances
tenantes permettez-nous de croire un
instant que le mot de responsabilité
peut avoir du sens pour un membre du
gouvernement la création et
l'attribution de l'argent du fond
Marianne sont d'ores et déjà une immense
tâche que seul votre démission peut
laver Fabrice Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas
trop qu'on lui dicte quoi faire non et
je dois avouer que un chef ça doit
chauffer je crois que c'est Chirac avait
eu cette expression c'est-à-dire que ça
doit assumer les responsabilités pour
les autres et je trouve que Macron a une
attitude systématique de soutien
jusqu'au si loin qu'il puisse aller ça a
été le cas pour Benalla ça a été le cas
pour les qui ont été mis en cause ça a
été le cas aussi pour Gérald Darmanin et
à chaque fois il a essayé de tenir les
choses et je trouve que pour le coup en
termes politiques c'est important
d'avoir un dirigeant qui va pas lâcher
tout de suite parce que un des gros
problèmes qu'on a il faut le dire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a de moins en
moins des chefs chefs on a de plus en
plus d'échecs qui n'assument pas leur
responsabilité c'est un des reproches
d'ailleurs qui est fait à Schiappa et
c'est intéressant mais je parle dans le
public dans le secteur public en
particulier qui se défaut qui rejette la
faute sur leur subordonnée et qui au
moment où leur subordonnée ont des
problèmes les lâches donc je trouve que
pour le coup c'est une c'est un exemple
qui est important qui parlait de
République irréprochable là voilà c'est
ce soutien mais au moins au moins lui a
une colonne vertébrale il soutient de
façon indéfectible sont secrétaire
général Alexis son homme de confiance
qui est pourtant mis alors justement
Emmanuel Macron qui soutient Alex
psychologue qui était
mise en examen pour prise illégale
d'intérêt écoutez-le ce qui est d'un
homme qui depuis plusieurs années
passent ces nuits et ses jours à servir
l'État avec un dévouement et une
intégrité dont je peux témoigner
dans une époque où respectant les lois
qui ont été votées il y a maintenant
près de 10 ans il n'y a plus
d'intervention dans les dossiers
particuliers et après que sur cette même
affaire l'enquête préliminaire est
d'abord classé le dossier
je considère que la décision je prends
tout à fait légitime Hélène voilà donc
c'est le soutien d'Emmanuel Macron à
lexicoleur mis en examen Alexis colère
Eric Dupond-Moretti également qui
renvoyait dans la cour de justice de la
République c'était quelques heures après
l'examen quand même en tout cas
c'est ça jurisprudence à Emmanuel Macron
a changé en 2017 quand il est en pleine
campagne présidentielle il dit quand
même en pleine affaire Fillon si moi
j'étais mis en examen je ne serai pas
candidat à la présidentielle et il
parlait d'un devoir d'exemplarité pour
tous ces ministres en disant et si j'ai
des ministres qui sont mis en examen je
leur demanderai de démissionner on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas
petit rappel quand même ça a changé
ces dernières années puisque rappelons
que François Bayrou avait des envies
avec la justice dans le cadre des
affaires des collaborateurs européens
ils n'étaient pas mis en examen qui lui
avait demandé de démissionner donc il y
a une évolution qui se qui se fait dans
le même dans le même type
effectivement on rappelle juste pour
l'instant
n'est pas mise en examen évidemment la
présomption d'innocence s'applique à
Michel il met un changement doctrine du
côté d'Emmanuel Macron oui je pense un
changement de changement de comportement
de la part de la justice on a quand même
vraiment l'impression que dans beaucoup
de cas la justice a les hommes
politiques dans le collimateur les
femmes politiques donc animateur et que
par conséquent la séparation des
pouvoirs fait qu'on qu'on n'est pas tenu
c'est ça la grande différence en
revanche qui m'a choqué dans cette
histoire de de fond Marlène shabbat
c'est que pour Marianne
c'est vrai mais c'est que je trouve bon
Samuel Paty est horriblement assassiné
mais est-ce qu'il faut immédiatement
créer une commission pour donner de
l'argent en faveur du séparatisme sans
même définir ce qu'est le séparatisme
sans qu'on soit d'accord sur qui on
combat là qui on combat et comment on
combat je trouve qu'il a aucune
discussion là-dessus et ça pour le coup
ça me choque on s'est empressé de réagir
on a su réagi et surtout oui ça mérite
peut-être un débat ça mérite un débat à
l'Assemblée des débats partout qu'est-ce
que le séparatisme et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire contre séparatisme mais un
fond comme ça quelques millions d'années
de toute façon ça résout rien autre
sujet Quel avenir pour la gauche anti
Mélenchon pas facile de se faire une
place en très manuel Macron et la nupes
et pourtant les candidatures se
multiplient la semaine dernière l'ancien
Premier ministre Bernard Cazeneuve a
réuni son mouvement et pour 2027 il y
croit fond écoutez-le
l'union de la gauche a été le combat
comme pour beaucoup d'entre vous de ma
vie j'y suis attaché viscéralement comme
vous je la désire ardemment comme vous
j'ai conscience quelle est la condition
du retour de la gauche au pouvoir mais
parfois les chemins empruntés pour la
réaliser ne peuvent en aucun cas
contribuer davantage à fracturer une
nation déjà si éprouvée ceux qui ont la
tentation de la stratégie de la
confrontation sur tout et à chaque
instant ne réaliserons croyez-moi ni
l'unité de la gauche ni lutter dès la
France la seule unité qu'il parviendront
à le réaliser et celle de l'extrême
droite et de la droite extrême au plus
grand détriment des français
Bernard Cazeneuve qui a également
déclaré la chose suivante devant moi ce
n'est pas une impasse que je vois c'est
une avenue large pour ne pas dire un
boulevard il a raison
un regard interrogatif et nuancé c'est à
dire d'abord il faut voir pourquoi cette
gauche là socialiste socio-démocrate
s'effondré c'est parce que elle a
divorcé des classes populaires qu'elle a
cessé de représenter leurs intérêts que
en 2012 les gens votent massivement pour
François Hollande pour une raison
socio-économique pas pour le reste et
que naturellement ils ne se sont pas du
tout retrouvés dans la politique menée
par François Hollande je ne suis pas sûr
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que je
suis interrogatif c'est trop tôt pour
dire mais je ne suis pas sûr que Bernard
Cazeneuve et les autres et un regard
autocritique sur cette question là du
social alors que pour le coup que ce
soit la France insoumise et plus
généralement la nupesse et même Olivier
Faure ont essayé de faire ce droit
d'inventaire là en revanche là où c'est
quand même un événement majeur et me
semble-t-il salutaire c'est que en effet
il me semble qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
en France qui sont un peuple de gauche
qui est veuf d'une gauche qui est
humaniste d'une gauche qui est
internationaliste d'une gauche qui ne se
range pas du côté de tous les dictateurs
de la planète d'une gauche qui ne nous
dit pas que que ce sont les États-Unis
qui provoquent la Russie
et sur cette question là notamment et
d'une gauche par exemple qui ne dit pas
à des policiers pendant une perquisition
la République c'est moi et de manière
comme ça un petit peu violente donc je
pense que si vous voulez il y a une
forme de division qui est c'est pour ça
que je suis assez pessimiste avec d'un
côté une gauche qui a raison sur le
social et tort sur le sur le reste et
une autre qui a raison sur le reste est
tort sur le social vous n'êtes pas
raisonnable fabrice est très raisonnable
et justement Bernard Cazeneuve et cette
gauche là c'est une gauche très
raisonnable qui a vécu un crash
absolument terrible après la fin de la
présidence Hollande l'annonce capacité
de se représenter de de ce président la
candidature du Premier ministre Valls ou
primaire qui se termine vraiment
dramatiquement la candidature un monde
qui est un effondrement encore plus donc
il y a eu cet effondrement qui fait que
en réalité on n'a jamais fait vraiment
le bilan de
la présidence Hollande on a en tête
grosso modo que le président était
peut-être pas ce qu'il fallait mais bon
ces résultats économiques ont été à la
base du décollage macroniste par la
suite donc il y a cette situation et en
revanche quand on les écoute et quand on
les regarde
je devrais pas dire c'est des gens que
j'aime beaucoup en plus c'est pour
lesquels j'ai un immense respect mais ça
fait vraiment dépasser en fait quand je
les écoute je me souviens de l'Italie
des années 90 il va les années 90 il y
avait un parti qui est le Parti
socialiste Parti socialiste connaît un
crash à cause des questions de
corruption bettinocraxie part en exiles
en Tunisie etc et ce parti qui a
représenté 15% des voix se retrouve à
0,5% des voix et tout d'un coup toutes
les valeurs socialistes sont
ringardisées plus personne ne se
souvient de qui était tourati en France
qui se souvient de Jaurès alors il y a
Mélenchon de tête qui va le citer dans
un discours mais au fond tout ce filon
social-démocrates avec Bloom existe
en fait ça n'est plus une symbolique
politique qui parle
juste une symbolique politique au fond
qui est un peu comme un vestige quand on
regarde parfois dans une cathédrale
certains vitraux on voit bien que c'est
joli que c'est artistique mais au fond
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement
Hélène Bernard Cazeneuve 2027 alors il
parle d'un boulevard Bernard Cazeneuve
je pense que il est il est très
optimiste il faut je pense que la
social-démocratie son espace est très
faible aujourd'hui en France mais
l'espace existe alors on est entre
l'aile gauche de la macronie on
s'acharouillé à les barbara Pompili et
l'aile droite de la nups si tentait
qu'elle existe bon c'est tout ça ça fait
1,71,7% à la présidentielle
maintenant je pense qu'il y a des il y a
des signaux faibles qu'il faut qu'il
faut regarder d'abord vous en parliez
Nathan c'était
cette crise passion en fait de jouer
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça c'est le
dénominateur commun sa crise et ça ça
peut agréger et puis je pense qu'il y a
eu une élection législative partielle
qui a eu lieu il y a quelques mois qui a
amené Martin projet à l'Assemblée
nationale elle a battu une candidate LFI
elle a réduit le macronisme à 10% dans
sa circonscription et c'était la
candidate dite sociale démocrate c'est
une force Carole Delga anidalgo amicale
de la fosse entre autres je pense que
c'est des signes faibles auxquels il
faut faire il faut faire attention et
puis les européennes CE seront un test
aussi quand on regarde les autres pays
où ces produits le même crash de la
social-démocratie en réalité c'est la
gauche extrême qui s'est recentré et qui
a pris la place c'est le cas pour le
parti démocrates en Italie voilà de
cesser la même chose je pense qu'il se
passe en Angleterre donc je pense que
c'est le maire de Rouen Nicolas meilleur
Rossignol et socialiste et anti-ups sur
le plateau de Public Sénat il a lancé un
appel à Bernard Cazeneuve qui lui a
quitté le parti socialiste au moment de
l'accord de la nupes écoutez le maire de
Rouen c'était il y a quelques jours sur
public on a besoin de tout le monde et
que si on commence à dire sous prétexte
de rassemblée qu'il faut exclure je
pense qu'il y a une contradiction dans
les termes c'est pas parce qu'on a tel
âge non il faut être lu sur le fait que
le monde a changé et que donc on a
besoin d'un logiciel je pense beaucoup
plus écologique par exemple c'est vrai
que le Parti socialiste a longtemps été
assez productiviste bon là il y a des
changements à mettre en oeuvre le monde
a changé et puis il faut aussi qu'on
évite le social populisme pour le dire
rapidement c'est-à-dire éviter
l'outrance et puis éviter les tabous
Michel seringue ce discours comme le
disait tout à l'heure Fabrice je suis
pas sûr que c'est un gars mais je suis
sûr que Macron a bouleversé le jeu c'est
ça qui explique quand même que le
territoire que le domaine de la
social-démocratie ce soit ce soit réduit
c'est que entre le social libéralisme à
la Macron le social-démocratie tel que
Hollande l'avait défini le 14 janvier le
fameux 14 janvier ou enfin les mots
sociaux démocratie ont osé sortir de sa
bouche c'est vrai que les choses ont
beaucoup changé mais je pense moi qui a
quand même qu'il peut y avoir un espace
entre
quand même
tout à fait dans le chef est quand même
maintenant très critiqué
très moi je trouve très très dévalué par
ces prises de position incompréhensible
ou des faisceaux de d'humeur bon je
pense que on fait l'union de la gauche
quand François Mitterrand a fait l'union
de la gauche il a fait de l'avion de la
gauche sur le centre de la gauche
généralement on fait pas une union sur
ces extrêmes donc à partir de là j'en
conclus qu'il y a peut-être une place
pour une tisane démocratie mais alors si
c'est une avenue le problème c'est que
il y a pas de conducteur pour le moment
il y a beaucoup de débats sur les mots
sociaux démocratie on entendu le maire
de Rouen il parle de social populisme
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire vous
Nathan ce mode social populiste pour
désigner Parti de la France insoumise il
me semble que ce mot n'est pas une
erreur c'est à dire que la stratégie du
populisme c'est pas une insulte qui est
projetée de l'extérieur c'est quelque
chose qui a été théorisé de l'intérieur
c'est des travaux de Chantal Mouffe qui
ont intéressé Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2017
qui décide en 2017 d'abandonner un petit
peu le terme de gauche pour faire une
référence au peuple et c'est ce qui fait
sa campagne là-dessus et c'est une
stratégie qui marche donc et c'est toute
la question de ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est qu'à mon avis il a
raison Jean-Luc Mélenchon de voir que le
Parti socialiste a un moment est
complètement sorti des raisons pour
lesquelles les gens votaient pour lui et
c'est à dire des raisons purement
socio-économiques enfin essentiellement
mais si vous voulez tout ce qui est allé
derrière c'est à dire sa géopolitique
c'est-à-dire une forme de véhémence dans
le dans le discours c'est à dire une
forme parfois de de démagogie tout
simplement tout ça si vous voulez en
effet créer une forme de de socio ou de
social
cette semaine l'Italie a organisé des
funérailles d'État pour dire adieu à
Silvio Berlusconi mort lundi à l'âge de
86 ans actuel chef du gouvernement
italien Giorgia Meloni a rendu hommage à
celui qui aura passé le plus de temps au
pouvoir depuis la création de la
République italienne écoutez
loue et l'État il y a avec lui l'Italie
a appris qu'elle ne devait jamais se
laisser imposer de limite elle a appris
qu'elle ne devait jamais renoncer avec
lui nous avons mené gagner et perdu de
nombreuses batailles et c'est aussi pour
lui que nous atteindrons les objectifs
que nous nous étions fixés ensemble
pour voir Silvio
c'est une filiation entre Meloni et
Berlusconi au niveau voilà sur on
parlait de populisme moi je suis pas
d'accord enfin j'étais pas du tout
d'accord avec cette idée de Berlusconi
populiste pour moi Berlusconi quoi qu'on
en pense c'est l'homme qui a fait
rentrer l'Italie dans la deuxième
République c'est à dire qu'à partir de
1994 quand il fait ce qu'on appelle la
descente dans la reine quand il descend
en politique il fait il produit par son
entrée en politique par les stratégies
qui va déployer il produit la
bipolarisation qui était espérée
attendue par les Italiens pourquoi parce
qu'elle permet l'alternance et au fond
c'est gaëtano un historien italien qui
depuis était devenu sénateur très
conservateur qui disait Berlusconi veut
faire en Italie ce que de Gaulle a fait
en France c'est-à-dire que la Cinquième
République c'était ça la possibilité
d'avoir deux blocs qui s'affrontent et
effectivement il constitue un bloc avec
les les postes néo-fascistes de John
francofini et allianza national et dont
Georgia Meloni elle héritière et il met
aussi dedans la Ligue lombarde donc qui
met dedans les populist mais son idée
est avant tout d'essayer de faire une
droite avec une coalition comme De
Gaulle a été amené à le faire en
s'alliant avec Giscard d'Estaing une
partie des centristes pour pouvoir
gouverner je vous traduis bien Fabrice
il n'a pas affaibli la démocratie
italienne Michel vous êtes d'accord avec
ça je suis d'accord au début je suis pas
d'accord à la fin alors expliqué qu'au
début j'ai trouvé moi j'ai entendu
j'étais en Italie parce que j'ai entendu
le premier discours de Sylvie wallusconi
président du conseil c'est un discours
formidable un discours ouvert un
discours qui faisait sa place
justement au libéralisme social bon
c'était absolument prenant mais il se
transformer en clown quoi
progressivement pardon de le dire mais
avec beaucoup de qualité c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui a toujours préféré
ses intérêts personnels l'intérêt de la
finvestre par rapport c'est faux il sort
il sort appauvri du pouvoir c'est-à-dire
que la il était il était la première
fortune d'Italie
quand il sort il n'est plus à première
fortune Italie et il est même ramené
plutôt vers la 5ème
question se pose quand même enfin il est
le deuxième il est le deuxième 2e
miracle italien c'est à dire l'Italie
des années 90 vit bien elle vit bien
parce qu'il triche vis-à-vis des
instances européennes parce qu'il était
mais il fait de la croissance
au début c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
qu'au début je trouvais que c'était tout
à fait et je trouve quand même qu'il a
fini dans le ridicule vous pouvez me
dire
vous l'avez rencontré je crois
personnellement on l'a rencontré
beaucoup de gens l'ont rencontré en
France quand il essayait de faire la 5
et moi j'avais été stupéfaite par le
côté charmé de François Mitterrand de
Laurent Fabius à l'époque devant le
personnage qui et je me rappelle bien
voilà si la télévision française avait
ça c'est formidable et il n'y avait
qu'une seule personne à l'époque qui
disait attention c'est Jacques Lang qui
a dit attention l'attitude du CD de
Berlusconi ça va être la fin du cinéma
italien ça a été la fin de cinéma
italien sur la culture en tout cas
j'attends que c'était était le seul à
s'être opposé à Mitterrand sur ce point
précis donc je trouve quand même que la
fin et les bons gars bons gars
un équilibre pas malheureusement le
début j'adore c'était un serviteur de
l'État c'est un homme d'État c'est
dans son cours sur le Platon ils disent
si on veut comprendre Platon
il faut lire Aristote et voir ce que ça
a donné alors on pourrait avoir un
raisonnement analogue sur Berlusconi si
on veut comprendre Berlusconi même si
c'est un peu injuste comme méthode
voyons quel est song politique à
l'international et il me semble que on
peut quand même dire que Berlusconi
c'est l'annonce du trumpisme que c'est
vraiment l'annonce de ça c'est à dire le
la figure du du très grand bâtisseur
initialement admiré par toutes les
élites médiatiques culturelles etc parce
que c'est un personnage formidable qui
qui fascine c'est un self maidman il est
très sympathique et puis il me paraît un
peu inoffensif politiquement et puis qui
est pris dans une sorte de de spirale du
Brice qui ne s'en qui n'en finit pas et
qui si vous voulez alors en effet il y a
ce côté là où il peut construire une
forme de de politique plus forte etc
mais un moment il y a une continuation
entre la figure du grand bâtisseur
capitaliste et la figure de du politique
qui à mon avis est dangereuse alors que
quoi qu'on dise la comparaison entre le
général de Gaulle et Berlusconi en tout
cas sur le plan psychologique me
semble-t-il là où elle ne fonctionne pas
c'est que le général de Gaulle quand il
arrive au pouvoir il n'a pas derrière
lui tout l'orgueil tout lubrise de se
dire je suis le plus riche je suis le
plus beau je suis une star de parfait
voilà oui mais c'est pas le même orgueil
de dire je suis le Sauveur métaphysique
d'un peuple ou je suis quelqu'un qui a
gagné à la grande jungle de la lutte
capitaliste en France la classe
politique a réagi à la disparition de
Berlusconi on va écouter Emmanuel Macron
cette semaine
j'ai eu l'occasion plutôt dans la
journée d'exprimer les condoléances de
la France
au peuple italien
suite en effet l'annonce du décès de
Silvio Berlusconi il un grand
entrepreneur il a marqué la vie
politique italienne des dernières
décennies et nous transmettons
évidemment au peuple italien au
gouvernement
italien nos condoléances réaction
également d'Eric Ciotti qui écrit sur
Twitter véritable monument de la
politique en Italie et homme d'État qui
la servi de toutes ses forces il était
un fervent défenseur de l'amitié entre
nos deux nations réactions du sénateur
LR Stéphane Le rugulier la mort de
Silvio Berlusconi laissera un immense
vide au sein de la droite européenne
Hélène il y a pas une fascination et
peut-être quelque chose comme là un
inspirateur des droites européennes et
des droits de françaises
qui se sont
emprisés de réagir et de façon assez
élogieuse alors oui à Eric routier mais
il y a aussi la droite plus extrême
Marion maréchal et Jordan Bardella qui
sont les deux personnalités politiques
je pense qui ont été les plus élogieuses
Marine Le Pen a également rendu hommage
à de faire jusqu'au ni mais de façon
assez sobre c'est sa méthode en ce
moment mais ça c'est il y a pas trop de
secrets c'est parce qu'elle est dans
cette stratégie de normalisation qu'elle
ne veut pas faire de vagues Marine Le
Pen sur Emmanuel Macron on a entendu ici
son hommage on a aussi reçu nous le
communiqué de presse de l'Élysée très
souvent quand il y a un décès de cette
nature il y a quelques mots qui sont
écrits qui viennent de l'Elysée là
c'était je c'était assez flagrant parce
que il y avait quelques lignes seulement
il y avait un hommage mais c'était
calculé d'habitude lorsqu'on reçoit les
ce qu'on appelle les notes de rédaction
les communiquer de presse de l'Élysée on
a quasiment toute la biographie très
élogieuse de ce type de personnalité là
c'était plus sobre Fabrice aspirateur
des droites européennes nous dit le
dessinateur s'appelle le régulier il est
un des un des premiers à dire en Italie
on peut utiliser le terme de droite
chanter centre droite c'est quand même
comme ça qu'on en parle parce que
la droite avait été contaminée par le
fascisme donc lui il dit on est centre
légitime quand même ça et il rellégitime
une forme de discours néoconservateur
sachant que à l'époque on a le
conservatisme britannique qui est là et
lui mais autre chose alors que les
États-Unis de Bill Clinton ne sont pas
encore façonnés au code qui vont être
définis donc c'est ça son apport
politique c'est ça après il y a la
vulgarité il y a la malhonnêteté les
formes de truanderie la magnificence
mais la principale critique qui lui a
été faite qui avait été faite à son
premier gouvernement quand John
francofin il y a entre le patron d'Alien
de sa nationale et c'était que en fait
on avait affaire à du néo fascisme et ça
il faut quand même le dire ça a été un
jeu que la gauche a beaucoup utilisé
qu'elle a utilisé aussi en France contre
Nicolas Sarkozy et c'est là où on voit
les outrances du vocabulaire politique
parce que il n'était pas il était pas à
fasciste il est battu en 96 Romano
produit prend la suite très
naturellement il reviendra par la suite
il sera à nouveau battu donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est important
quand même de dire que dans le dans
l'époque on a tendance à insulter les
adversaires politiques à créer des
fables et je trouve qu'aujourd'hui on
vit un moment comme ça où pour les uns
et Mélenchon le fascisme pour les autres
c'est Macron et pour les autres encore
c'est Marine Le Pen donc je trouve que
ça nous permet de faire le bilan deconi
de se rendre compte aussi de la
caricature du débat politique l'OTAN est
tellement en train de se réveiller de
cette torpeur vous vous souvenez
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait déclaré il y a
4 ans que l'Alliance atlantique était
dans un état de mort cérébrale et bien
cette semaine a débuté le plus grand
exercice aérien de son histoire 10 000
soldats
issus de 25 pays y participent et
écoutez ce soldat allemand qui explique
l'objectif de la mission
avec rdfendeur 23 nous montrons où vont
et démontrons la capacité de défense de
cette alliance le signal de cet exercice
n'est dirigé contre personne c'est un
signal pour nous dirigé vers l'intérieur
vers l'OTAN ce sont principalement des
pays de l'OTAN qui cet exercice
coordonné par l'Allemagne pour montrer
que nous sommes capables de défendre ce
pays et cet alliance sofa trading Nathan
ses exercices de temps c'est un signal
envers Poutine
de répondre
Poutine en tout cas c'est le c'est un
signal c'est ce que c'est le mot que
vous avez employé c'est le directeur de
la CIA qui avait dit cette phrase que je
trouvais très juste que le raisonnement
de Vladimir Poutine sa pensée politique
qui avait justifié la guerre en Ukraine
était une pensée qui reposait
exclusivement sur des Axium faux il faut
et contradictoire c'est à dire que d'une
part il y avait la vision d'un Occident
la vision un peu paranoïaque d'un
Occident qui cherchait partout les
moyens à faire tomber le régime alors je
ne suis pas non plus naïf sur le fait
qu'il y a des intérêts etc mais que mais
que c'était con enfin c'était une vision
hyper trophiée et deuxièmement il y
avait la vision théorisée par les
doublis etc d'un Occident complètement
décadent complètement faible avec à
l'échelle locale cette idée que
zellenski allait quitter Kiev dès le
jour de l'invasion parce que cet
homme-là venait du showbiz et qu'il
avait pas du tout la carrure et le
courage pour rester il a fait le
contraire avec cette idée que l'Union
européenne était une civilisation
dégénérée enfin tout ça c'est théorisé
c'est une la vision décadente enfin la
version décadentes de l'Europe Greco
greco-chrétienne et l'Union européenne
s'est réveillée au moment de la guerre
en Ukraine et avec à l'échelle de l'OTAN
cette idée que l'Occident aussi était
dans une posture de faiblesse parce que
il l'avait été notamment en Syrie et
donc là ce qui est réveillé l'OTAN donc
il a réveillé le temps c'est ce que vous
nous dites oui donc parfois on dit qu'il
y a des prophéties auto-réalisatrices là
c'est presque l'inverse c'est une
prophétie qui a réalisé l'inverse de ce
qu'elle de ce qu'elle disait on va juste
rappeler ce que c'est que le temps le
temps c'est 30 pays aime ça garantit une
assistance militaire automatique c'est
un si un des pays membres est agressé
par un autre état c'est le fameux
article 5 40 000 militaires mobilisables
et prêt au combat ça fait peur à Poutine
ça Fabrice
je crois pas je crois pas c'est un état
du monde qu'il connaît cette
organisation du Traité de l'Atlantique
Nord existe depuis 1949 donc imaginez
alors
elle s'est réveillée oui c'est vrai
factuellement et justement il a il a une
crainte supplémentaire par rapport à
deux autres de de ses voisins et c'est
pour ça que il mais je pense que ça l'a
ça l'a déjà ralenti parce qu'on
imaginait déjà la taxe suivante sur la
Moldavie et on voit bien qu'elle est
pour l'instant pas totalement à l'ordre
du jour peut-être que je me trompe
peut-être que la semaine prochaine ce
sera le contraire mais on a cette
impression et puis la deuxième chose par
contre c'est que ok ça l'a réveillé mais
les dissensions internes ne sont pas
complètement finies à l'intérieur de
l'OTAN bah oui il faut pas être naïf on
voit toujours qu'il y a une opposition
entre les pays de l'Est de l'Europe
comme la Pologne qui sont directement au
contact des pays comme le nôtre qui sont
un peu moins
menacées donc qui parfois ont une
attitude un peu plus distancier et puis
la question de la Turquie reste toujours
posée la question oui mais c'est très
important il y a eu des élections il y a
pas longtemps et on voyait bien côté
français que certains brûlaient des
cierges pour que erdohann éventuellement
perdre donc donc on voit bien que c'est
pas c'est pas résolu et que cette
Turquie qui peut dialoguer avec l'Iran
qui peut dialoguer avec la Chine qui
dialogue avec la Russie ben elle elle
est pour nous pas forcément un atout par
moment elle est un élément de tension la
place des Américains aussi fait beaucoup
fait encore beaucoup réagir je vais vous
montrer juste à contribution à
américaine aux exercices qui ont débuté
cette semaine les Américains envoient
une centaine d'avions et 2000 tonnes de
matériel écoutez Dominique de Villepin
qui réagit justement à ce rôle américain
dans le dispositif de l'OTAN c'était sur
le plateau les amis de C dans l'air ce
jeudi
le temps a gagné en puissance en Europe
avec le déclenchement de cette guerre et
ça
c'est effectivement une garantie pour
les Européens mais nous savons tous
qu'il y a une épée de Damoclès au-dessus
de l'OTAN qui est la nature du soutien
dans la durée que les Américains
apporteront à cette organisation s'il y
a des élections aux États-Unis qui
amènent la victoire de Donald Trump ou
de quelqu'un d'équivalent et bien ce
soutien apparaîtra pour ceux qui l'est
c'est à dire
relativement hypothèque Michel se rôle
des Américains dans l'OTAN ça a toujours
fait parler
en France le temps s'est réveillé parce
que c'est le parapluie devant une Europe
qui n'a pas qui n'a pas assez d'armement
bon c'est vrai que enfin l'OTAN c'est
quand même l'Amérique ça veut dire oui
l'Amérique intervient maintenant dans
les affaires européennes et se vendent
d'intervenir dans les affaires auto
européennes donc effectivement le temps
c'est
rallumer encore moi je trouve que quand
on dit
la guerre du crâne
refait des robes
je suis pas d'accord du tout parce que
je trouve que jamais l'Europe n'a été
aussi divisée qu'en ce moment on le voit
très bien à Fabrice vient d'en parler
les pays
du nord de l'Europe ont une politique
particulière laisse on voit bien la
Pologne qui demande une intervention et
parce qu'elle se sent concernées
nous-mêmes les Français sont pour mais
enfin sans avoir l'audace des Anglais et
enfin les Allemands donnent l'impression
de tirer les problèmes du jeu pas
seulement parce qu'on les voit là et
qu'on les a entendus à partir de temps
moi je pense que loin de d'unir l'Europe
l'OTAN a été réveillé mais sans doute
pas l'Europe c'est pas exactement ce que
ce que pensent les manuel Macron on va
l'écouter c'était il y a deux semaines
en déplacement en Slovaquie on va
l'écouter
oui une Europe de la défense un pilier
européen au sein de l'OTAN est
indispensable c'est le seul moyen d'être
crédible pour nous-mêmes d'être crédible
dans la durée de réduire nos dépendances
et de prendre cette part légitime du
fardeau qui est le nôtre j'avais en
décembre 2019 une phrase sévère à
l'égard de l'OTAN soulignant à l'époque
je vous le rappelle les divisions qui
existaient en sont saints entre la
Turquie et plusieurs autres puissances
en parlant de mort cérébrale je pourrais
dire aujourd'hui que Vladimir Poutine la
réveiller avec le pire des électrochocs
Poutine qu'elle avait le temps ou Macron
qui a réveillé le temps et l'Europe
Poutine tout de même réveillé l'Europe
et une forme d'union au sein et une
forme de volonté de souveraineté
militaire au sein de l'Union européenne
quand il dit ça Emmanuel Macron quand il
plaide pour un pilier européen au sein
de l'OTAN quand il dit qu'il faut une
installation là dans la durée il faut
que ce soit il faut avoir une force de
frappe en profondeur qui viennent de
l'Europe en cas d'offensive c'est un
message qui est directement adressé aux
États-Unis c'est une façon de dire nous
aussi on doit on doit s'organiser on
doit pas rester sous la houlette
américaine plus d'un message mais pas
une réalité en tout cas c'est une
volonté et ça et c'est ce que ça a
réveillé je pense que Poutine a réveillé
l'Europe en ce sens rapidement mais non
mais c'est vrai qu'il l'a réveillé
notamment sur la question de l'armement
et des industries d'armement et c'est ça
que le président a en tête en permanence
parce qu'on est dans une situation en
fait où les Américains sont là ils
disent nous on va vous fournir leur
maman qui vous faut on va vendre et nous
français on est producteur et donc on se
retrouve à devoir chercher des marchés
extérieurs généralement pro Poutine pour
exporter nos armes donc ça devient
gênant quand même comme chacun
de cette émission par un top flop je
vous pose une question très simple qui a
marqué l'actualité de la semaine en bien
ou en mal Helen vous commencez votre top
de la semaine qu'est-ce que c'est alors
mon top c'est pour Roland-Garros alors
c'est pas pour les joueurs français
parce que cette fois ils ont été
éliminés jusqu'aux même deuxième tour il
était là non le top c'est pour le
dispositif qui a été mis en place contre
le cyber-harcèlement des joueurs Roland
Garros a décidé de leur permettre en
fait de lutter contre les messages
haineux qu'ils reçoivent visiblement en
permanence dans le milieu du tennis
voilà il se scanne un QR code avant de
rentrer sur le cours et quelques heures
avant et ça leur permet de jouer
sereinement et visiblement ça a été très
efficace de la semaine le flop c'est ce
drame
avec cette mort de plus de 60 au moins
79 à migrants au large du Péloponnèse en
Grèce en drame qui est du nom c'est
catastrophique on c'est vrai que c'est
fatiguant de de lire ce genre
d'information donc 69 79 migrants à bord
d'un bateau de pêche ils étaient
visiblement 750 les recherches sont
encore en cours et ce qui est quand même
ce qui pose question c'est que
visiblement des avions de Frontex donc
l'agence qui surveille les frontières
avaient repéré ce bateau et à essayer
d'agir et pas vraiment voilà ça pose
question et je trouve que c'est scandale
votre top de la semaine alors j'ai deux
tops le premier commence comme un flop
mais c'est la cagnotte de pour
Jean-Pierre Léaud parce qu'on a appris
et on a appris là il y a cette semaine
qui vivait dans des conditions de vie
absolument terribles de dénuements
financier catastrophiques que ça le
déprimait qui sortait plus de chez lui
donc ça fait réfléchir de se dire qu'on
peut être une star du cinéma une légende
et vivre ainsi et il y a une cagnotte
qui a permis de lui rapporter beaucoup
d'argent et l'autre top c'est la Légion
d'honneur qui va être donnée aux à Henri
et alors c'est intéressant parce que
j'ai vu beaucoup de gens enfin certaines
personnes à gauche disant Henri a l'air
d'être très à droite quand même etc moi
je pense que l'héroïsme dans ces
conditions là n'a pas de couleur
politique et qu'il faut le saluer Michel
votre top mon top c'est les Français
sont addicts maintenant à la poésie
addict accro j'exagère mais en tout cas
on a on a augmenté la lecture de la
poésie d'après les libraires a augmenté
de 22% pendant ces six premiers mois je
trouve que dans une période de déprime
générale que c'est pas mal vive la
poésie vive la poésie et votre flop et
mon flop c'est le
conseil qui vient de dire que le 49
troll l'usage du 49-3 était
soulève des interrogations au regard de
la séparation des pouvoirs alors moi je
veux bien je me demande pourquoi au bout
de 65 ans parce que la Cinquième
République a quand même 65 ans et
ensuite il me semble que dans la volonté
du général de Gaulle de la Constitution
il y avait un équilibre un système
présidentiel un système parlementaire et
qu'effectivement la possibilité d'une
motion de censure peut rassurer le
Conseil
Fabrice votre top de la semaine mon top
c'est des gens dont on parle pas souvent
c'est la section de recherche de
gendarmerie de Loire-Atlantique basée à
Nantes qui a résolu l'affaire Karine
esquivillon et qui a fait avouer Michel
pial et donc je salue leur général
relance à mort et puis mon flop alors
mon flop c'est le rejet par l'Assemblée
nationale de l'amendement de Guillaume
Garraud dont l'objectif était de
répartir les médecins pour essayer de
réduire les déserts médicaux et pourquoi
je pense que c'est un flop parce que je
considère que la droite et l'extrême
droite notamment et le groupe
Renaissance ont pris position en disant
c'est pas bon on va être en Union
soviétique phrase de Marine Le Pen je
trouve que c'est honteux parce que en
fait ça donne l'impression qu'on cède au
lobby et notamment au lobby du monde
médical c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous les quatre merci d'avoir
pensé merci président l'archet
évidemment salut à vous derrière votre
écran on me dit dans l'oreillette que
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous suivre un immense merci à vous je
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même jour
même heure et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]